good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Thursday hope everyone's
having a great day I know I am oh my God
I'm being annoying sorry because I am
sitting down with my best girlfriend
Miguel pal Jack yo hey girlie hi Adam so
you just have our best friends
are we not no I know we sound like that
Tick Tock sound that Tick Tock sound no
we're best friends we could be honest
about it wait I'm sorry I didn't know
this was like like something we needed
to be honest about we're literally best
friends what the [ __ ] are you talking
about I know like if someone asked me
privately like who's my best friend I
would say Claudia but like I don't think
we've ever admitted to each other that
like we're each other's best friends
I I didn't think it was something like
we needed to be admitted to like if
somebody nobody asked me this because
I'm not in the seventh grade okay but if
somebody did say like Claudia who's your
best friend my answer first would be
like of course my sisters right but then
but nobody asks for that reason they
want to know like who in your life is
your best friend and I'm very blessed I
would say I have about six best friends
right which is why with when you give
that answer like then
I expect that to be your answer so when
you said I was your best friend it's
just it still feels special I know we're
not in the seventh grade but like to
hear someone call you their best friend
like it's such a mark of specialness
that's so funny that you say that
because like I often do find myself like
hanging out with like lifelong friends
from like high school and stuff but also
like friends
um in that I've made in the last couple
years being like I'm your best friend
right because like you're my I say to
Taylor's tracker all the time she has
like so many best friends and she does
say I'm her best friend she does say
like you know you and stassi which is
like sure okay you have to bring salsia
but like yeah like I'm always getting
like my friend Abe I'm like you're my
best friend like I'm your best friend
right because what's more embarrassing
than having someone as your best friend
and then not having you of course but
the thing is like it's just
grammatically incorrect to have six best
friends
so to have six people who are your best
friend because it's a singular
experience
who would you say like outside actually
this is like a contentious conversation
because so many of our friends like
listen to the toast because they're so
supportive and wonderful but I was going
to ask like who your best friend is
yeah no I wouldn't say it on the toast
that's how see that's how like private
and and big of a deal it is and personal
and then it also begs the question do
husbands no no that just makes it too
complicated and then nobody ever could
be a best friend again
because really at the end of the day if
I'm thinking of like who do I like
really share the most with
I think it's bad yeah no technically
your husband your partner is your best
friend it's the person that you spend
the most amount of time with in your
life I've been seeing like a lot of you
know inspirational educational quotes
that say like the person you choose to
be your partner is so important because
it is the person that you will spend the
most time with for the rest of your life
like not just you know it's the
potential father of your children like
this that it's like who do you want to
spend actually all your time with nights
what
nights what's nights
who do you want to spend your nights
with
like okay end your days
no of course like you could spend your
days with multiple people but like when
you get into bed you watch TV you read
you lay you can't sleep you wake up like
that is the person you're really
spending like the most minutes away no
but yes it's about minutes and when you
look if you were to put a graph of how
many minutes you spend with Ben versus
how many minutes you spend with me your
Taylor Striker Abe everyone like the
amount of time you spend with Ben is so
much more so you better like him so much
more than you like even your friends
but I'm saying back to my Knights point
those minutes are at night unbalanced
because so many of the minutes are at
night like I'm never gonna get into bed
with anyone other than Ben unless Ben
starts being mean to me and then I'll
show him who's boss yes the minutes are
it oh
speaking of husbands I sent you
something yesterday I know there's a lot
of really good stories today I have it I
have it oh okay because I thought it was
like so funny and it's a Gabrielle Union
story that I want to talk about but
we're we're embarrassed by riches in
terms of this election on today's
stories you know Liz Lemon once said
when it rains it pours some days we're
talking about Mary from Sister Wives
literally for 30 minutes and some days
we cannot be contained to simplify
stories and today is one of those days
just because our first story there are
like a million sub stories because a
copy of Harry Prince Harry Windsor's
Memoir has been leaked to the guardian
and like there are so many headlines and
the Bombshells revealed but I I feel
like what's so bombshell-worthy is not
the stories themselves but the fact that
he's saying that he's telling the
stories right because it's really like
personal behind the scenes family stuff
yeah
yeah and honestly like I'm so fatigued
by the Royals like specifically Harry
and Megan I feel like they really should
have timed their documentary and then
his sit-down interview and his book a
little bit better because now it's going
to be two to three months back to back
of just non-stop stories and it's it's
so big that you can't ignore it
especially you know he's a uh the
alleged uh altercation getting physical
like you can't ignore it but like I just
want to like preface by saying like I'm
so over this family like I need but
here's the thing I saw only yesterday
this morning all the other stories came
out yesterday I saw like there was
alleged physical altercation and
honestly like I was planning to ignore
it like I don't care that the brothers
had a tussle like that's what brothers
do it's yeah for some reason that's like
the biggest story that's come out but I
think of the other ones that I read this
morning like some of them are crazier
and more interesting
well I haven't read them because like
I'm getting to the point where like I
literally don't [ __ ] but I also am
really into the fact that there's all
these headlines and stories because I
don't think I'm gonna read the book so I
want to know as much as I can by not
reading the book
no I'm not reading the book either I
it's so funny how what got me into
reading was celebrity Memoirs and I
could not tell you the last one I read
actually it was Jeannette McCurdy and um
Josh Peck I read two last year they were
both excellent I have to say Josh Peck's
book I find myself thinking about all
the time I really enjoyed it when I was
reading it I think I even gave it five
stars but I often think about like
things he experienced or just like like
lessons he was learning and takeaways I
cannot recommend the book enough and the
podcast good guys a TNN show speaking
last year media of TNN shows new episode
of the redheads came out today
I heard and it's just a blast because
when I was looking for stories I saw it
in pictures of course because you know
we're just those relevant topical
news-making Queens everywhere and it's
the first episode of 2023 which is so
exciting it's really a great time to
become the redhead and the first book
was this Mitch's Choice which is really
accessible we read the Girl by Ruth Ware
it's a thriller and personally I was
stumped now it's on my list let me ask
you a question we were talking about
this on the redheads do you think it's
the author's responsibility when doing a
thriller to leave enough like
breadcrumbs along the way that it's
possible for you to guess or do you
think a really great Thriller is like
wow I could have never seen this coming
such a good conversation I think it's
not only applies to books like movies
too
um
no I don't think that the author is
required to give us breadcrumbs having
said that it can't be Dan is Gossip Girl
like it can't have been physically
impossible for the twist to actually be
true so I want to be surprised but I
don't want to be like I just wasted all
my time because there's no [ __ ] way
that's possible yeah okay I I do agree
with you Dana was saying like it's there
should be enough context clues that like
a really shrewdreader can figure it out
and I agree and now looking back all of
it's there and and she was setting us up
for it but I I never in a million years
could I have guessed it so I think the
perfect example of like a thriller with
a Twist is Shutter Island literally I
could not have guessed the ending of
that movie if my life [ __ ] depended
on it the second time I watched it I'm
like oh my God I'm a [ __ ] like it
really it is the perfect Thriller film
and that's why we're constantly
referencing it here at the toast because
nobody has ever done it better
is acquainted Tarantino Martin Scorsese
of course it is Martin Mr Martin yeah so
I want you to read the it girl and I
want your thoughts but you know what I
watched recently that also had me
thinking about this is the Glass Onion
that Knives Out sequel okay so me and
Ben fell asleep and believes watching to
it actually sorry I fell asleep and like
an hour later I woke up and he was still
watching it so I went back to bed and as
I was falling asleep I was actively
trying not to like listen
um so I didn't finish it I don't know
what happened I know the premise I got
up to the part where they find out that
like Daniel Craig and his horrendous
accent
um actually weren't meant to be invited
like I really only made it so that
literally happens in the first 20
minutes yeah
um so it was really bad and though I
never I did not guess you know the
twists and turns I don't think anybody
really could have but it was just bad
regardless whether or not so that's the
other thing that's the other thing with
a thriller is sometimes they'll just
like have a bad twist that's not even
good and like then you don't care even
if the twist had been good I wouldn't
have cared and I think maybe the twist
was good but the rest of the movie was
just like so bad and all the characters
were like so terrible and unlikable
I only made it again 20 minutes and I
agree but I do love seeing Kate Hudson
in a movie like she is so everything of
the sort she's such an IT girl and she
looked amazing and I didn't make it far
enough to start disliking her character
so I'm gonna maybe just not finish it
yeah no you I want you to watch it but I
do think that they kind of describes the
knives out name because the first movie
was just such a juggernaut
the first movie was incredible yeah and
this was not that this was just like you
know similar to like murder mystery Adam
Sandler and Jennifer Aniston on Netflix
yes yes yes
well that's also because it was just
like an influx original and knives out
was
a full theater experience yeah
well also speaking of podcast excited
about the redheads but also some
exciting like housekeeping news about
next week
um so I am headed to LA tomorrow and
I've decided to spend the week there
first because I'm saying yes to life and
I have to say I'm already regretting
saying yes to life
um nevertheless she persisted you
already said yes to this one
right I already said yes but you know
what like I'm gonna be happy and it's
gonna be fun and exciting I haven't been
to LA in a long time and I decided just
to spend the week there and do all of
the toast episodes from La I've never
been to the deer media studio
um so next week we will be running on La
time so for our East Coast girlies just
keep that in mind for the scheduling I'm
also we had an interview scheduled and
the person actually lives in La so I'm
just going to go to La and do it with
that person there I think people are
going to be kind of Shook at this guest
it's
it's kind of crazy it is kind of crazy
and definitely not what you would expect
but I think it's going to be great and I
think that's oh no it's not your first
time doing a solo interview but first
time in a while like not since I was
pregnant
no now I'm like nervous like you're
gonna be great honestly I there's I
think it's you should be less nervous
knowing that you like we're not that you
worry about like colliding with me for
talking but no I don't you don't but in
case that was a worry like it's gone
yeah but then it's like my God there's
no one to collide with right right no
but you're so conversational and you
always have your next question lined up
it'll be great yeah no and I have to do
a lot of prep I'm gonna go in really
prepared so next week's gonna be a busy
busy week L.A girls so if any of my la
like people want to like have me on
their podcast like I'm just putting an
official oh yeah you should do the
rounds
which is official memo I haven't booked
anything like social memo like I'm going
to be in LA and um I would love to do
with that information what you will Los
Angeles
do with that information what you will
Los Angeles
um so I went to the Nick game last night
I saw
and Ben you know text me of course
couldn't give me any less notice like 3
30 games at 7 30 you want to go and I
was like running between appointments
and I had calls and then I ran out to
get BOTOX and I was so like looking
forward to a night of just like nothing
and then I remembered I was saying yes
to life so I was like okay and then Ben
did tell me they were Courtside so I was
like oh of course yeah I'll go you were
saying again to courtside yeah I was
saying yes to Wood that's what everyone
calls it wood you know I didn't know
that and I was really I was more so
saying yes to like all the free food
that comes with wood you know the Delta
Lounge JP Morgan Lounge I got to like
have a full sit-down meal at halftime I
didn't know about all the other with all
the celebs you know
[Applause]
Tracy Morgan who I did get to meet like
very briefly and it was like I'm a I
don't think there's actually anyone in
the comedy space besides Joan Rivers who
I like respect and love and and just I'm
obsessed with more so that was really
that was very exciting
um zeeway was there I was in the
elevator with z-way and Matt Damon was
there and a ton of like you know former
athletes who Ben was excited about and I
hadn't um you weren't familiar I wasn't
familiar with somebody from stranger
things they put you know when you're
when you do like the celebrity row at us
at a game they put like a clip of you in
a movie or on TV and then they show you
at the game so they like familiarize the
crowd with who people are and so they
put up the thing from stranger things
and I looked up for a second and I
thought it was Elliot Stabler and I'm
like screaming I'm like
and Ben is so confused and then they
show the guy from stranger things who I
swear to God I've never seen in my life
and I'm like wait what Ben was like I
was wondering why you were screaming
like you don't does the guy look like
Elliot Stabler
no but like in the clip they showed from
stranger things like it looked like
Elliot's table so did they show your Say
Yes to the Dress clip and then you shut
up no they did not no they would show I
guess a clip of the toast
I I mean if it'd be nice
um I did uh
I did get triggered this morning
um I was scrolling Tick Tock and like a
toaster had made a tick tock of like a
clip from our Say Yes to the Dress and
people were comfy like more and more I
had to scroll right what was it like it
was like just it was it was you guys
being like you should put on a crown
and I was like I mean if you guys like
want me to put on a crowd I put on a
Crown like it was oh
it was
it was really painful
um I know I know that I probably
wouldn't be sitting in this exact chair
if it weren't for Say Yes to the Dress
like you know every decision in your
life leads you to the next one a
butterfly flaps its wings and I have
diarrhea you know
but
that doesn't make it any less painful or
triggering damn
I still think back fondly on your
episode I thought you were so cute
you know when you watch the whole
episode
it's not as great but like you know here
they just have like a cute clip of you
and you're so funny you're like I don't
like the top I don't like the bottom and
I don't like the middle
no okay here's the thing you know they
always say like you shouldn't get
married young and I feel like I'm living
proof that that's actually not the case
however my episode of Say Yes to the
Dress is great proof for
for the notion that getting married
young is never a good idea you shouldn't
go on and say Yes to the Dress young
right because you never know what
opportunities might scare you across
your desk when you're merely 21 yeah
even though on the whole the episode is
so cute and it's not like like we
thought we were doing something
oh my God I think I watched it and I was
like proud
same I thought it was so great I thought
like
I thought like who could dislike us
right
oh
so yeah I was triggered this morning I'm
sorry send it to me will you no
yeah I couldn't even find it if I wanted
to I scrolled over right past it got it
got it
um sorry to bring that up so early in
the morning but it was only top of mine
because you posted a funny thing
yesterday on your Instagram story about
it yes I don't want to say Yes to the
Dress I want to say yes to life yeah
saying yes greater than saying Yes to
the Dress
yeah so I'm saying yes to life day like
three or four I'm already regretting it
but I had such a good time at the game
and I honestly if I hadn't made this
resolution I would have said no and I
would have told Ben like go with one of
your friends who will like actually
appreciate the game and like you know uh
you'll have so much fun with them and I
really I did have a good time in the
next one which they never do and it was
like I'm glad I went and that was the
whole point in saying yes to life
because I know when I go to things like
I'm always happy that I went but I don't
know what it is it might be like
seasonal depression or just like
laziness but I never want to go to any
even at like okay we were having this
conversation like in July we had gotten
reached out to yeah for like a dream yes
yes on this show
um they told us that this particular
guest loves the toast which was
something we had thought and we were
overwhelmed and it got delayed and then
whatever it never ended up happening but
while like we were in the process of
planning it like you and I were saying
to each other like this is so big and so
major like I hope it gets canceled yeah
no we were like if it didn't didn't
happen like we wouldn't care but I don't
know it would be enough for me to know
that she listens to the toast Ed wanted
to come off yeah that was enough that is
and it still is
it still is and if she's listening and
she wants to reschedule like of course
we will come to you of course you are
always welcome here
um but I can't lie like I don't know
what that is it's like when major things
happen and when major things don't
happen I'm like not mad when they don't
and like when they're happening I'm like
I wish this got canceled yeah maybe it's
just nerves I think that for that it's
just nerves I think that's different
than like not wanting to go to events
events I want to go to events events
events I want to go to that's another
thing also like I could tell you I think
anyone can tell you like going to the
Nick game Courtside with your husband is
going to be a good ass time no of course
and I'm just like a wedge yeah like it
was amazing but I'm just like tired and
lazy and like I give everything to this
job like I really do like when we do the
toast like I'm giving 100 of my
personality my energy my humor when
we're done and we're working we're
making content we're taking meetings
like I give a hundred percent of myself
to this job so when the clock strikes
like 5 36 like I'm ready to do [ __ ]
nothing nothing for myself I recharge by
doing nothing not spending time out with
friends and family no that doesn't that
drains me even further yeah
but also going back to Shutter Island
and events events I want to go to events
another piece of art that I find myself
constantly thinking of and like
um
referencing is that comedy special The
Twist she's gorgeous I keep saying
events events I want to go to events
invite me to your events what's the
comedy special for everyone who has
between it The Twist she's gorgeous it's
on Netflix cat Cohen it was one of my
favorite specials I watched this year
was it's so so good
it's so good so
um it's just interesting what sticks
with you yeah
like movies books TV shows like you love
it in the moment then you never think
about it again or like you like like it
and then you find yourself like being
actually like impacted by it months
later yeah that's what happens with
books all the time we were just talking
about that on the redheads how we need
to rewrite every book we've read because
like when we look at what we've rated
high and what we've rated though like it
makes no sense
no but that's what like art is Art
should make you think for long periods
of time yeah
should make you uncomfortable
and personally I'm getting comfortable
being uncomfortable I don't think that's
true I don't ever want to be feeling
uncomfortable me
inconvenienced I will not have it no
no I'm I'm not like that I'm actually
not comfortable at all being
uncomfortable no
all about comfort
and what's so exciting about and you
didn't answer my text or my phone call
last night you must have been asleep
um and then you'd answer in the morning
so you just like most people call me
this morning
like last night uh because I was
scheduling studio time at Deer media and
they were sending me different pictures
I think I was available studios in the
studio I landed with has a bugle chair I
saw this morning
so if that isn't Kismet meant to be
transatlantic Wonder then I don't know
what is transatlantic it's like take
this as your sign Tick Tock take this as
your sign to use this podcast Studio
100 yeah no a buccal friendly
environment is a toast friend we love to
see it she was like we have this studio
available with window and this with a
buccal chair and I'm like did you say
Buckle chair no she's like I said boucle
you illiterate no I call it swine it was
via text so it was Boogle yeah and it is
Google
mm-hmm
lots of stories I think we can dive in
because much to discuss okay so without
further uh did it did it do here are the
fast guys oh the stripes brother and I
miss those boys miss them together
that's the hard part about saying yes to
life is that I'm spending a lot of time
you're saying no to Theo
if I didn't have such an amazing like um
travel care for Theo
Ben's parents like I I would feel bad
but I don't even feel bad in the
slightest Theo's like great I can't wait
to go back to my grandma I was like I
hate it here yeah but you could also
take him with you
I could you could also send him down to
his aunties to play with his cousins
I could just things to think about
things to think about things in which to
think while you're thinking about it
make sure to catch the past five stories
that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business Squarespace is
everything to sell anything they have
the tools that you need to get your
business off the ground including
e-commerce templates Inventory
management a simple checkout process and
secure payments whatever you sell
Squarespace has been has merchandising
features to make your products look at
their best online so whether you're
running a side hustle a full-blown
e-commerce business Squarespace is a
great place to start if you're looking
to build a website on their e-commerce
templates are so easy to use you don't
have to have a degree in like software
engineering to use it you can design the
website of your dreams without all the
complicated you know code that is
normally required Squarespace makes it
easy to sell and just get up and running
because
you just gotta start when you're when
you're out of business side hustle or
not like you just got to start and
Squarespace is going to help you start
also one of the great Parts is that you
can connect your social media accounts
so you can display posts from your
social media profiles onto your website
automatically push website content to
your favorite social media channels so
your followers can share it too so if
you want to check out Squarespace go to
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use the
code toast to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain
um so again that is squarespace.com
toast the offer code is toast to save 10
off your first purchase of a website but
when you go to squarespace.com toast
you'll get that free trial and then when
you're ready to launch offer code is
toast for 10 off your first purchase of
a website or a domain they make it so
simple from start to finish if you have
a ton of experience or very little get
your business off the ground with
Squarespace today's episode is also
brought to you by Noom when we decide to
lose weight it's not usually just about
the number on the scale whatever the
reason is for wanting to make a change
new weight is ready to help they're
different they use psychology at noon
wait to help you understand your eating
habits and learn how to make healthier
choices every day if you eat because
you're bored or you can't pass up food
when it's just around and free if the
answer is yes do not stress NuMe weight
can help you break the cycle and change
your habits for good what I really like
about Noom is this notion that like
weight isn't just physical like there's
so much that goes into it in your brain
and numa's tackling weight loss
psychologically which I think is a
really healthy and sustainable way to do
it
um weight will help you recognize a
problem and change that problem whether
that's like food fomo like if everyone's
eating and I'm not hungry like I'm just
gonna eat because that's how my brain
works so numa's gonna tackle that for me
um you also learned it's like a lot of
interesting insights about your habits
like maybe you don't even know that like
you eat when you're bored or you when
you're not even hungry you just eat for
some sort of like oral fixation
um it's really interesting to like look
inward on your psychological eating
habits
new weight uses psychology and that's
why they say losing weight starts with
your brain the program helps you
understand the science behind your
eating choices and why you have cravings
to date NuMe weight has helped more than
4.6 million people lose weight and
everyone's journey is different so your
daily lessons are going to be
personalized and tailored to you and
your goals stay focused on what's
important to you with new weight's
psychological based approach sign up for
your trial today at noom.com toasts
that's n-o-o-m.com toast to sign up for
your trial today
and check out their first book the new
mindset a deep dive into the psychology
of behavior change available to buy
right now wherever books are sold great
thank you so much mclared you're welcome
our first story is All About the leaking
stories from spare Prince Harry's new
Memoir the first probably biggest story
that everyone is in a tizzy over is that
Prince Harry claims William physically
attacked him over Meghan Markle in his
Memoir Prince Harry claims in his new
Memoir spare that the older brother
Prince William physically attacked him
per the guardian in an excerpt obtained
by the outlet Harry claims that William
called the former's wife Megan quote
difficult rude and abrasive which Harry
goes on to describe as quote a parroting
of the press narrative in response Harry
writes that William Unleashed on him
in response to what like he called him
difficult her difficult we're going to
embrace it and then in response he
Unleashed
well that wouldn't be a response that
would be a further quality okay wait she
said it all happened so fast so very
fast he grabbed me by the collar ripping
my necklace and he knocked me to the
floor I landed on the dog's bowl which
cracked under my back the piece is
cutting into me I lay there for a moment
dazed then got to my feet and told him
to get out he claims that the alleged
altercation left him with a visible back
injury and the heating the heated
exchange with William occurred at
Nottingham College after he expressed
interest in discussing Cottage after he
expressed interest in discussing the
rolling catastrophe of his crumbling
relationship with Harry Harry claims
that William was piping hot during their
chat after insults were exchanged Harry
writes that William claimed he only
wanted to help his younger brother
um okay first of all that little excerpt
I find like shocking in terms of the
writing style it feels like very um
like basic I laid there my back hurt you
know like
no sorry I don't know if it feels basic
but it's like Elementary no it does feel
if I don't know to me it feels like the
opposite not like you know incredible
prose but just like
like storytelling
storytelling yes so I do agree I'm
trying
I really
I don't like this man like I know I feel
like I I never finished the Harry and
Megan thing because like life got in the
way but from the first three parts like
my takeaway like I was really
um
I was really kind of wowed by Megan and
I was really kind of like uh by Harry
and so now I'm just because I never
finished a documentary and I don't know
if this is accurate I'm just like Harry
like stop I mean anyone who speaks ill
of someone's wife like it would make
more sense the story is just confusing
because like it would make more sense if
William said something nasty about Megan
and then Harry right but like he said
something nasty and attacked him and
then punched him that's double whammy
no yeah I just feel like this is Harry's
truth yeah
I think there's a lot of it and I'm sure
if we heard
at William's side of the scuffle it
would be biased towards William like
there's you know three sides to every
story Harry's Williams and the truth
yeah but I just think it's one I think
like brothers fight I think like boys
like you and I if we had a disagreement
it wouldn't I don't think it would ever
really become physical physical
um I do think with Brothers like it does
not to you know I don't condone that or
anything but like you gotta you know you
rough him up a little no then I also
think this is like a an instance of like
perception and language because you know
you could
tell this story and be telling the truth
and you know chalk it up to like a
brotherly scuffle or you can like almost
dramatize it a little bit like my back
was injured like you can they're both
true right the word I don't see this
attack could have many different degrees
of meaning right so that's interesting
that I when I saw this I wasn't like
blown away because at the end of the day
that is what brothers do I don't see I
look of course we don't know the Royals
at all but I see William as like
reserved and like weird and like
conservative so I honestly I can't even
picture him like getting all hot and
bothered over Megan yeah I just we need
more to the story but then also it makes
me think about the documentary and how
like they never really talked about
anything with William and Kate other
than like Megan saying that they were
much more formal than she expected
privately and that um then when they're
leaving he gets in uh he was upset with
how William's office like handled
squashing that rumor yes but it's like
so they were fighting there was a
physical fight like where was that when
you're telling the whole last story oh
my God that's so true that's what it is
it's like we thought we knew everything
in Oprah then it turned out this
documentary came out and not only was
there so much more but also it did kind
of conflict with some of what they were
saying on Oprah now it's like the
sit-down interview in the book and it's
like well I thought this was telling
your whole story in the in the
documentary yeah
I'm just getting fatigued you can only
tell your story so many times honestly
like yeah
it's like mine it's like I agree so
that's like what people are quaking over
though I don't think like brothers
fighting is that crazy but here are some
more headlines
in Harry's book he says King Charles
made quote sadistic jokes about Prince
Harry's quote real dad
right King Charles made sadistic jibes
about Prince Harry's real father the
prince reveals in his new Memoir Harry
38 grew up amid public speculation that
his true father was Princess Diana's
former lover major James Hewitt the
prince writes in his new book spare how
Charles seemingly enjoyed making her
comments about his parentage in one
segment scene by Page Six Harry writes
quote Paul liked telling stories and
this was one of the best in his
repertoire he'd always end with a
bursting with a burst of philosophizing
who knows if I'm really the prince of
Wales who knows if I'm even your real
father he'd laugh and laugh though it
was a remarkably unfunny joke given the
rumor circulating just then that my
actual father was one of mummy's former
lovers major James Hewitt one cause of
this rumor was Major Hewitt's flaming
Ginger hair but another cause was sadism
Harry said that the Tabloid readers
loved the idea that his dad was not
really Charles insisting and likely made
them feel better about their own lives
quote never mind that my mother didn't
meet major Hewitt until long after I was
born turn
oh well okay well that's an interesting
tidbit yeah
um
but go back what I don't get Charles's
joke maybe I'm not that's what I was
gonna say too that is weird like he
would just philosophize that's his word
who knows if I'm really the prince of
Wales who knows if I'm even your real
father what's this maybe that's like him
maybe that's like him playing on tabloid
culture I don't know it's definitely an
inappropriate joke to make to your kid
for sure yeah
but it's interesting that those rumors
did penetrate the walls of Buckingham
Palace right but I feel like it's like
when there's such a crazy rumor about
you that's so untrue and I feel like
even like you and I couldn't relate to
this on a small level like we joke about
it all the time
yeah
that's a way of coping but it's also
probably really hurtful for Harry
because like his mom's not there too of
course it's just like this thing that
kind of hangs over him and Charles is
his only parent and now he's saying well
maybe I'm not like no Charles is a dick
like it's not funny I didn't need Harry
to tell but I don't understand the rest
of the joke I feel like
not in Charles's defense but like I feel
like he's trying to say something else
but by saying who knows if I'm really
the prince of Wales is he saying that
Queenie stepped out
right right no I don't get the joke at
all but like I do feel Harry and and I
think what his takeaway here is like my
dad is a prick and I feel that
yeah
because I get like two to joke about
outlandish rumors about yourself like is
helpful when coping with them
um but at the end of the day you're also
a parent and like that's inappropriate
yeah
next headline
you're going to be thinking they're
gonna be interested in this Prince Harry
claims William and Kate told him to wear
the Nazi costume
oh my God you're [ __ ] kidding it's
Harry sensationally put some of his the
blame of his Nazi uniform Scandal on his
brother Prince William and his
sister-in-law in his new memoir Prince
Harry claimed that Kate and William
howled with laughter when they saw him
dressed up for the 2005 party Harry was
20 years old when the Sun newspaper
published a photo front page photo of
Pinterest as a Nazi with a red armband
emblazon with a big swastika the picture
was taken at a costume party with a
native and Colonial theme where William
was also a guest and was dressed in a
homemade lion outfit
in one segment of the book obtained by
Page Six Harry writes about choosing the
outfit revealing that it was a toss-up
between two costumes a pilot or a Nazi
Oh I thought it was going to be a Nazi
or black face
he said I phoned Willie and Kate asked
what they thought Nazi uniform they said
Harry writes adding that when he went
home and tried it on for them they both
howled worse than Willy's leotard outfit
way more ridiculous which again was the
point
okay what I find really interesting was
that in the first part of the
documentary like they they talked about
that and how Harry's like really you
know working hard to become actively
anti-racist and taking accountability
for his problematic past
um
and then it seems like this book is like
he wants to like kind of shove
accountability a little bit onto his
brother like let's say that this is how
it happened like when you are trying to
like learn from your mistakes and grow
like you don't
shift blame onto other people you take
responsibility you take full
responsibility and that's that you don't
like make excuses and even whether this
is true or not like it definitely you
know he diminishes his accepting
responsibility for it by placing blame
yeah with his brother and honestly I
can't tell if I'm just in like my hating
Harry Windsor era but like I
ah
I don't know I don't see it you don't
believe it
and maybe that's because like I'm
definitely like
annoyed with Harry
you know what's so interesting I
actually met someone when I was in
Belize who is from the UK and it came up
and I feel like the difference in like
UK and American discourse when it comes
to these four is so different
um and the conversation of Harry's
paternity came up and the conversation
of the documentary and I felt like
the conclusion we both really came to
was that like and I don't think this was
how they meant for it to come across but
like my major takeaway from that
documentary was like so many things
failed Megan like the system failed
Megan the family failed Megan but like
most importantly her husband really
failed her he did not
protect her he did not really prepare
her like she thought there was going to
be this whole orientation into becoming
a royal and there wasn't and her husband
didn't step in at all and help her with
what to wear and how to act and how to
curtsy and which Fork to use
um and that left her feeling really
vulnerable and I don't even think she
she didn't blame him but like from the
outside I'm like well your husband grew
up in this
shouldn't he be the one to help you yeah
and if he can't help you find like a
teacher for you yeah so like I'm really
seeing this all now through the lens and
my perspective on this has changed so
much over the last years every time I
learned something new but my perspective
on it now is like Harry really
um
amongst all the people who were involved
like I feel like Harry failed Megan the
most yeah but I also feel like that's
why he's making these huge
steps and really like just like turned
his back completely on the whole system
because he's kind of ashamed of how he
handled it and wants to do right he even
said when he was that's interesting he
said that specifically about when Megan
first started struggling with her mental
health that when she first came to him
that he didn't support her and have her
back in in the way that she needed and
that he was ashamed of that and so now I
think and I think it's the same way you
know maybe he was more firm oriented
than boyfriend husband oriented and so
he's course correcting in these huge
major ways oh that's interesting I
didn't know that part
um
that like he wasn't like 100 there for
her when it came to her mental health so
yeah that's where I'm at currently so
what did the person from the UK say
like that everyone is just like tired
and the uh the paternity thing it's like
well now it seems even more relevant
that Charles is
um
The Sovereign because a lot of people in
the UK like really do not believe Harry
to be a Charles's son
but what what it doesn't change anything
really because he still wouldn't he
won't be king
no but like now that he's outside of the
like he would like Grand was his Grand
like he had a relationship with Gran he
has no relationship with his father and
there's like crazy rumors that it's not
even his dad so there's no connection
yeah but Williams his brother
yes yes yes yes yes but they have no
connection either yeah
so that's the lens I'm currently seeing
the situation through and it's subject
to change but for me like Harry is the
villain here he really is yeah there's
also so I don't know I just feel like
he's doing all like you said these grand
gestures to support Megan and kind of
taking his brother and sister-in-law
down with him and I'm not just gonna
believe right outright that it was Kate
Middleton's idea for him to dress like a
Nazi like I I don't believe that like I
can understand by the way like I can see
I I don't ever think anyone should dress
like a Nazi but I could see how like
you're 16 and you think it's funny and
you're a [ __ ] moral like I can get I
get it yeah I get how something like
that happens it's inexcusable but I get
it people make mistakes so now 10 years
later to like quote-unquote take
accountability and then uh say someone
else's idea in your book I don't know I
just it feels very inauthentic to me yes
but he also cites it as kind of the
start of the break between him and
William because Harry was like felt like
he was left out in the cold and he took
the whole brunt of it when and William
came out you know smelling like flowers
when William maybe goaded him into
wearing it so I think he might in his
defense he might be sharing it to say
this was the start of like
tension between us
yeah I just feel like a a recurring
problem in the royal family with its
members and then people who join the
family is like they go through these
scandals or like tabloid drama and they
have to go through it alone and that
leaves them very isolated and they don't
feel supported I think it happened with
everyone even like what we saw on the
crown like with Diana of course but also
with Charles like everyone feels like
they don't have the support of the
family and the firm and like maybe they
should just start supporting each other
yeah but it feels like they're I don't
know who the firm is that's not a family
member because even the queen in her
early days like there were so many
things that she wanted to do that people
said that she could not do and that she
didn't like she didn't let Margaret
marry the man that she wanted even
though at first she was like go do your
thing right so it's like who is that
even in the documentary there's um in
the days where they're leaving but it's
not you know they're just taking a step
back it's like between step back and you
know
sayonara
um the queen Harry wants a meeting with
the queen she said like my schedule is
open come by and then he gets a call
from her peeps saying her schedule is
booked she can't see you but it's like
she's the [ __ ] queen
no but so that has to come from the top
like if the queen wants to meet with
someone her people will will arrange it
like I don't think that her people were
coming in between I feel like she didn't
want to [ __ ] talk but she said like
come see me I think that might be one of
the problems highlighting
it's like everyone is Too Faced like
they say one thing and then like their
team does another but the team is led by
the leader I think I don't think she's I
think they say one thing and then they
are convinced of another and then they
let the team do the legwork that's what
I think that's what I I feel like we saw
in the crown a lot that's interesting
you know she's like standing so firm on
something and then they're like no girl
can't be like that
I just uh I need a break from Harry he's
really annoying me
um
yeah well I mean it's only gonna rev up
the book comes out in five days and
there are way more stories and like just
personal and like comments private
comments that were made he shared a
comment that his dad made at Prince
Philip's funeral
um
to him about like him and his brother
getting along better and it's just like
I don't need to know the it the personal
feelings of a grieving son at his
father's funeral
it's so personal like this is airing so
much Dirty Laundry it's so uncouth I you
know I'm sure people in his family acted
badly towards him I'm sure he'd fall
with his brother and they disagree right
okay that's what families do I we don't
need to hear about it it ain't our
business it's not
and to go I agree and making it like
leading such a private life with a with
a family that's in the public but their
private lives they try to maintain as
much privacy as possible and
everything's still leaks so if there's
things that haven't leaked like now
you're the one who's just gonna put it
all out there
yeah no it's it's not how I would ever
do it yeah but that's just me yeah
so I'm sure there'll be more to come but
just that's what's there so far but I'm
also sure that these are the biggest
things because I don't think that they
will hold back then they'll you know
they'll start to try and pull
but I I must be so annoyed about it
would be so current I thought it was
going to be about his upbringing
yeah like a memoir yeah no but like
about his childhood about the role of
Despair and and like his the loss of his
mother I didn't even I honestly like
didn't even think his wedding and Megan
would be in it because he has two more
books to write for the publishing house
it's a three book deal
I've had enough so it'd be like spare
spare the sequel
hair the spare spare the trilogy
that's a lot like the loudest bear is
anyone else really fatigued by this like
I'm over it I'm ready to move on and
it's also so fatiguing because we'll
never hear the other side
should we just sit here and like you
trip it's not a fair fight try and like
play Devil's Advocate but write it to
the devil
you know it's so true by the way like
the the discourse on
all that they've released in the last
year is so unbalanced and it's almost
like not even a fair fight it's like
it's like fighting with a mute person
you're never going to get a rebuttal
there are two sides to every story and
I'm never inclined to just believe one
person's entire side I'm sure that a lot
of what Harry is saying is true and I'm
sure a lot of it like could be explained
differently from a different perspective
so it's really it's not entirely Fair
yeah
are you ready for our next story a
little more British drama news
yeah as long as it has nothing to do
with these people I'm like over them it
has to do with British drama
oh
yes I'm ready Ellie Goulding addresses
the rumor that she cheated on Ed Sheeran
with Niall Horan Ellie Goulding shut
down long-standing rumors that she
cheated on Ed Sheeran with One Direction
band member Niall Horan many years ago
she addressed the unfounded rumors when
a person commented on her Tick Tock
video from last week where she was
dancing to prep's cover of Harry
Styles's song as it was she captioned
the video quick boob check then where
birthday groovin one tick titers tick
tocker decided to get personal with
Goulding and accuse her of being
unfaithful they said can't believe you
cheated on Ed with Niall but slay FR is
that for real play for real she said
false but also slay
the thing for me is like this was never
a rumor this was just a fact like a fact
of life is that you know the sky is blue
and Ellie Goulding left Ed Sheeran for
Niall Horan one person for another no
and cheated on that was just a fact of
life I feel like Ed has written many
songs about her like it's like not even
Up For Debate and I didn't even know we
were debating this so for Ellie Goulding
who believes this not to be true like
that's [ __ ] annoying and I'm
surprised she didn't tackle it sooner I
don't think it's true
even before her her rebuttal because you
know what it's too good to be true
like that these the British drama
British stars and like it's Ed Sheeran
Niall Horan like she doesn't I don't
think so I think that was maybe that's
interesting nobody so maybe she cheat on
him with some random but this would be
if this was really a real love triangle
like it would have more legs okay the
weird thing to me is like I feel like
Ellie Goulding and Niall Horan are
Generations apart how old is Ellie
Goulding
Ellie Goulding is 36 Ed Sheeran is 31.
no
Niall Horan Niall Horan is he's probably
what's Harry's age
like 30. 29.
okay so there was like a big age not
huge but okay I just I wanted to settle
that
um I feel like Ellie Goulding actually
is like a really interesting
relationship history like remember when
her and Calvin Harris were like OTP yeah
that was so crazy yeah and we're gonna
need some new music is what we're gonna
we're gonna need some new music and
we're gonna need a new like celeb
relationship or even though I feel like
she did the circuit and like hated it
why do I think she's married
no I feel like like she got married
quietly
yes she's married to Casper Joplin in
2019.
oh so I guess we won't be getting a
celeb relationship from her no we won't
be and she performed at Megan and
Harry's wedding so
wow what an honor yeah what a great
she's so brilliant she's so British like
that's a great get
yeah well I have recently
um kind of started standing Niall Horan
like I follow him on Tick Tock and I
always liked his music but he's kind of
like funny and cute and like I feel like
he doesn't get like a lot of like the 1D
shot somebody was in One Direction he
was like like the fourth or fifth most
interesting like people were not I feel
like it was Harry and then Zayn and then
Liam and then Niall and then Louie
um but he really turned it around with
his solo career and he's so talented and
he releases such good music and he has
like a huge fandom now and obviously
it's not on the level of Harry but like
he's the second most successful out of
the One Direction people and I just find
that like I'm shocked by that I know I
saw him on tour
I know you did the flicker tour
and I just think not enough people know
about his song seeing blind with maren
Morris it's literally so he went on tour
with maren Morris I was there
wow that's a nice tour and snitch we had
counselor's Day Out
um
so good so good his album's really good
the one with Flickr
this town good stuff
yeah he's like super talented and really
cute and he was like blonde in One
Direction and I don't know if that's his
natural hair color but it wasn't the
right color for him and now he's like a
chestnut brunette and he has been for a
while and I feel like that's really been
a huge part of my stand-up and I'm
really happy for him and he loves Taylor
Swift and he's like so funny and I
really liked it when he dated Haley
Steinfeld like he's kind of like a like
a really good celebrity is he dating
anyone now
I don't think so maybe snitch
perfect do you think you would convert I
throw the snitch yeah
I would convert for the snitch hundred
percent
I really like I'm glad we spoke about
that like I'm really kind of into him
I'm in like my Nile error yeah no I like
all these people
um God there's no bad blood I would have
been here for it if there was
biggest flop in the One Direction
they've all done like different solo
things except like Louie he like maybe
has released one song yeah him I don't
think it's fair to say no because I feel
like he's been through a lot personally
like he lost his mom and his sister like
in the same year and I feel like he
didn't it's not like he didn't try I
mean sorry it's not like he tried you
know what I mean okay he just kind of
took but then like Liam tried really
hard and Zayn tried really hard and like
they both flopped I feel like it's a tie
for last place
between Liam and Zayn like Zayn started
out really strong Pillow Talk the Taylor
and then like he released a whole album
last year I'm like I couldn't find one
person who gave even a shred of a [ __ ]
well I think it's the elder abuse didn't
go to play well then I know I know you
don't know this but like Liam kind of
went viral on Tick Tock like in a
negative way like all these old videos
of him performing like at the start of
his debut like solo career that were
like cringe and he was like in a mall
and like people were making fun of him
like it
like the thing with Zayn is that nobody
cared the thing with Liam was like
people cared but like in a negative way
what's worse I don't know yeah but I
feel like Liam sometimes I listen to a
song and like he's on it you know yeah
he has like he's had some features
he has some teachers and isn't he a
father now so he's busy yes he's busy so
is Zane so is Zayn right busy I think
they're all except for no Harry and
Niall are not but
Cheryl and Zayn no Cheryl and Liam had a
baby which is weird because she was like
the judge on X Factor and then they
started dating
um
and Zayn has a baby I don't think Louie
does yeah
well number one One Direction said they
were going on Hiatus and like it's been
five years yeah no they're not coming
back together but we have to move our
hopes and optimism onto Little Mix
or Our Hope and optimism onto like maybe
a collab song with Harry and Niall like
I don't even think that's all that would
be so cute but Harry they're both
talented like he could literally be
collabing with
anyone Beyonce
speaking of collab did you see that the
Kardashians um have been using quite a
few Taylor Swift songs in their Tick
Tock and then North and Kim literally
did one yesterday to shake it off of
singing the lyrics like mouth I saw
North and Kim
that's pretty huge yeah I'm sure
Taylor's like sure
Taylor's like I'm not getting it no
she's just like oh so now you wanna like
you wanna chat yeah no I think it's not
gonna happen no and if I were Taylor
like I wouldn't I wouldn't either yeah
it's like it's too much and also not
everyone needs to be friends so I'm glad
you can enjoy the music it's fire flames
I've never known that I agree make your
little Tick Tock enjoy enjoy are you
ready for our next story
yeah Gabrielle Union says she felt quote
entitled to cheating in her first
marriage
Gabrielle I'm sorry this is funny this
is funny but we need to talk about the
ethics Gabrielle Union is opening up
about infidelity and how her first
marriage fell apart the actress recently
sat down on the armchair expert podcast
with Dax Shepard where she spoke about
her first marriage with former
professional football player Chris
Howard and how it was destined to fail
from the beginning she described her
marriage as quote dysfunctional since
day one she said she was definitely not
getting wife of the Year Awards quote in
my first marriage neither one of us felt
like the marriage should get in the way
of Our dating a part of it was like
keeping up with his activities like oh
that's what you're doing you're going to
feel this one and I just felt entitled
to it as well she said I was paying all
the bills I was working my ass off and I
felt like that's what comes The Spoils
of riches it was such a stupid
relationship that should have never
gotten out of the dating phase she also
recalled a friend gifted her and her
ex-husband a therapy session where the
therapist recommended the two separate
because they had quote nothing in common
she also added that the therapist said
the one thing you guys have in common is
other people so why don't you just be
with other people during the
conversation Dax also opened up about
his past relationship where he noted
that he was in an open relationship for
nine years and he regrets some of his
actions during that time to which Union
responded I wish I had more guilt for
some of that
ah okay I mean like the headlines about
this have been misleading like she's you
know indignant and like yeah I was
making more money I should have been
allowed to cheat that's not what she was
saying she was saying like at the time
she was younger I'm like that's really
how she saw things right but also the
headline is misleading because they
don't let us know that like it's a
pretty much an open relationship with
people too
no but then like the discourse around
like women who make more money being
entitled to cheat like people like had
something to say about it so okay let's
talk about that discourse but I just I
feel like a little bit of Justice needs
to be served for her because that's like
not what she said because they were both
with other people and why if she if he's
gonna be with other people like that
should entitle her to be with other
people
it was completely taken out of context
but people are like living for this
headline she felt entitled to cheat on
him because she was paying all the bills
and making all the money
and here's the thing I support women's
rights and women's wrongs so you know
what like I'm here for it yeah
um no I'm not because you have to think
about it in the reverse like if a man
ever said that or thought that like what
no no I'm totally kidding it's obviously
like we would send him to that island
with Louie Teresa's husband and we say
go to man camp and fix it take your
shirt off and go scream at the beach
yourself
yeah no obviously like money has no
bearings on
Fidelity like the two are totally
separate entities
um but I like kind of still think it's
funny it is funny but I hope that no
one's you know take getting life advice
from this headline
no because it's totally misleading and
completely taken out of context yeah so
either be in an open relationship if you
want to cheat or don't be in a
relationship
yeah or don't pretty simple
rare or a symbol are you ready for our
next story
is it the next story that's brought to
you by Thrive cosmetics yup
so Thrive Cosmetics is high performance
Beauty and skin care products that are
made with Clean Skin loving ingredients
that means no parabens no sulfates no
flashlights it's certified 100 vegan and
cruelty free and the name causes in the
name for a reason because every purchase
supports organizations that help
communities Thrive so Thrive Cosmetics
is a Fab brand that I'm actually wearing
today
um their most popular product is the
liquid lash extensions mascara I have
very straight latches I have long lashes
but straight ones and they have a hard
time holding a curl and I've learned
that a tubing mascara is probably the
best thing for me and the Thrive
Cosmetics one is really good it is a
vegan tubing mascara it is their best
selling product their proprietary tubing
formula dramatically lengthens each lash
from the root to the tip and it mimics
the look of lash extensions but without
the damaging glue and the expensive
Salon prices also their brilliant eye
brightener is a huge seller for them
it's a cream to powder highlighter stick
that blends and opens the Eyes giving
you an instant eye lift you can apply it
to the inner corner of your eyes to look
like you've had plenty of restful sleep
you could use it as an eyeshadow for a
perfect daytime lower or use the
metallic shades for an easy smokey eye
it's foolproof eyeshadow highlighter
stick that makes it easy to apply and
blend if you are not a makeup artist
these sticks are fabulous they're like
multi-purpose you can put them I put
them under my brow bone on my eyelid for
like a shimmer inner corner I love an
inner corner highlight on my Cupid's bow
also some of the different shades are
great for eyeshadow it's really great if
you're not like super Fab at makeup
so now's a great time to try Thrive
Cosmetics for yourself you can get 15
off your first order when you visit
thrivecosmetics.com toast that's Thrive
Cosmetics
c-a-u-s-e-m-e-t-i-c-s.com slash toast
for 15 off your order today's episode is
also brought to you by Branch Basics so
Branch Basics is everything of the sword
it is a cleaning supplies company that
is going to give you everything you need
in one little kit so it's non-toxic
hypoallergenic free of fragrance hormone
disruptors and harmful preservatives it
is baby and pet safe it is clean and
cost effective so we've got little Theo
little Bruno little roldini running
around you really got to be careful
about what types of products you're
bringing into your home whether that's
surface cleaners laundry detergent and
Branch Basics is fabulous because it is
a totally clean brand that is
multi-purpose products so the one
concentrate can be used for everything
it makes a laundry detergent it makes
hand soap it makes dish soap an
all-purpose cleaner a bathroom and floor
cleaner it literally replaces every
single cleaning product in your home and
their refill model is fabulous because
once you run out the only thing you need
to repurchase is the concentrate and the
oxygen boost so start looking inward
about what products you're bringing into
your home a lot of cleaning supplies
have crazy chemicals and we just like
accept it you know but Branch Basics is
getting everything you need to keep your
home clean fresh and smelling good but
also free of those toxins like fragrance
hormone disruptors preservatives it's
hypoallergenic and it's non-toxic
so we have a code if you want to get 15
off any starter kit from Branch Basics
use the promo code the toast at
branchbasics.com we recommend the
premium starter kit for all of your
cleaning needs it's a great place to
start great entry level product again
that's code the toast at
branchbasics.com code the toast for 15
off awesome our next story Wedding Bells
Are Ringing for Ashley Olsen as she
marries artist Louis Eisner in a secret
wedding ceremony
TV star turned High fashion Mogul Ashley
Olsen married her longtime Beau artist
Louis Eisner in a hush hush ceremony at
a private Bel Air home last week sources
exclusively told page six they hear that
only a few dozen guests attended the
event on December 28th specifics about
the ceremony are unclear but one Insider
told page six that it went late with 50
people or so total the two have been
dating since 2017 but the couple are
intensely private and rarely appear
together in public there's only even
like one red carpet photo of them from
an attempt event they attended last
September
I mean everything the Olsen's do is so
Chic but like all the details coming out
about this like 50 people Bel Air he's
an artist like so [ __ ] chic chic like
I could never be this she's an artist
but he's a nepo baby
you know he's not even she he's not like
a starving who are his parents so his
mom I think is a jewelry designer and
his dad was once president of the David
Geffen company
oh that's like Mage don't even get Finn
like I don't even know who that is or
what he does but it's like major money
yeah okay good you've left it that's
Chic sorry chica Chic everything that
Olsen's do is Iconic and this is just
like so elegant and like we know nothing
about this wedding so we're just left to
our imaginations and I'm sure it was
just like [ __ ] Chic and like tasteful
not like over the top a million roses
just like so classy that cost a million
dollars but you would never know yeah I
would love to see a dress like I really
would there's such taste makers
mkna and I'm gonna hope against hope
that she does like that she did like a
little Vogue something we could get a
photo yeah it's just you know that's
what we need we need to be inspired we
need to be uh aspired and we need to
know it's dark like a community as a
culture we need to be elevated and only
Ashley Olsen's wedding dress can do that
for us it's dark times out there Ashley
Olsen has a responsibility to humanity
to lift us up yeah and I think I think
she could maybe be open to it
no I think the best and only chance we
get is like a very small Vogue exclusive
yeah I just one picture of the dress
that's all I need
yeah I'm sure she made it herself I'm
sure it's the row yeah
it would be great for the brand if they
need a little publicity but I think they
do fine
I think by the way like the row is the
uniform for like Rich classy girls
everywhere everyone is like throw pants
like something Navy's always wearing the
wow
when I tell you I don't own one thing
from the row I'm like the opposite of
their
um clientele I'm like fat and and like I
wear lots of colors well not today but
like I wear like just basic [ __ ] like I
don't think
I'm their target demo yeah no I don't
think I own anything either
it's so expensive like four expensive
sake
it's so expensive and it's not like
diamonds it's like a t-shirt yes they
make Basics they do make Basics and I
think a t-shirt you know shouldn't be
that expensive but there are some things
like I remember to have this like bag
ones that was so expensive like it was
real skin you know that does it was like
a bag that looked like a real bag but I
think it was like real croc or whatever
so that costs money
yeah
um like I would love to be a the row
girl like Morgan Stewart is the rep you
know that guy Charles from Tick Tock
Charles gross let's talk about it he is
the RO he's always wearing like the real
pants the role plays the row trench it's
so elegant it's so Chic and it's so not
me yeah so I think we just need to see
what Ashley's wearing I mean if she
wanted to show a picture with her
bridesmaid Mary Kate that would be
really sweet
um
think about it ladies
think about it take us it's just like
it's it would heal the world I think
it would definitely do something to the
world like when they showed up at the
Met Gala and like we're a photographed
together on the red carpet for the first
time since they were literally in Full
House like that reset fashion it reset
culture like come on give us something
yeah it's true we need a reset
but I'm also really like when I look at
them like to me they're a Hollywood
success story like they managed to kind
of evade
Fame like they had it they had
they were the A-list young Hollywood
fashion acting like they had it and I
don't think that they liked it and they
over the years like managed to slink I
think they lead very normal lives yeah
and they're extremely successful and
still work in the industry I'm
passionate but they're doing what they
want to be doing and they don't and a
lot of celebrities do what they want to
do but they also have to do the other
stuff that they hate to Selena able to
do the other but no but no
no I like I feel like nobody even talks
like to me they're like a case study for
like
they got out yeah they got out and who
knows what would have happened they were
so young and so impressionable and so
famous and like who knows what could
have happened but I don't know what
whether like they're you know they're
really good parents or they didn't want
to be famous anymore I don't know what
it was but like the motivation but I'm
so happy for them yeah and I do think
that they had their struggles like Mary
Kate of course a rough time
I you know what they need they need to
like sit down and do a podcast like I
would love to know more documentary
no it's a documentary is so like
hey look at me no but it's actually a
protest to other people in your life
they can like add clips of things that
they like said over the years it's hard
to reflect on your own life and like be
so certain of like what those moments
and choices that you made were where
that were inflection points you know
what I mean
but I honestly think we have a better
chance of getting them to sit down and
do a podcast than we do of them ever
doing a documentary like a documentary
such a big production yeah but someone
else can do it someone else can really
do it yes it's months and years where
it's like a podcast it's like an hour I
know but it's an hour of I don't know
would you rather someone I mean you
would do both in a second I would like a
production with a with a weekly podcast
every time a new episode comes out yeah
no but like for uh documentary it's like
Harry and Megan didn't make their
documentary they sat down for those
interviews and and then it was done and
their story was told right but then
you're also putting your story in
someone else's hands yeah and they
didn't love what Liz did they didn't
like it this was Liz's Vision that's how
Liz sees it sees it
right yeah
maybe we need it to be from the other
one Elizabeth
huh the sister
oh my God that is like such a crazy
let's talk about that first of all I can
be the only person who's constantly
confusing Elizabeth Olsen and Dakota
Fanning like they're literally and also
Elizabeth's
um Scientology James Moss
no I I get confused because I always
think her name is Elizabeth James
because their old clothing line
Elizabeth and James their siblings
um
Elizabeth Olsen like literally coming
out of the woodwork nepo Queen and just
like becoming
to laying the house down becoming like
such a well-respected artist and actress
like it's so Random for sure though I do
have to say I respect I think she slays
the game I don't think I've ever seen
one thing that she's in
I saw her in that Hulu show where she
played that girl with the eyebrows who
killed who convinced her boyfriend to
kill himself remember yeah um she was
excellent she was the girl in that
Michelle yeah she was incredib
are you sure she was a girl in that
positive I'm not seeing it on her movies
and TV she's also most people know her
from Wanda vision
which I never saw okay now you're gonna
make me go Elizabeth Olsen Google
Elizabeth Olsen Hulu Michelle murder
girl
Love and Death no I'm just not seeing
Michelle murder wait sorry no maybe it
was it am I not thinking of who
Elizabeth Olsen is
the girl from Plainville
yeah yeah okay the girl from Plainville
is played by Elle Fanning you're right
you really do get them I'm getting them
confused okay
wait
oh wait so no you've not seen Elizabeth
Olsen in anything she's in it let me
she's an Avengers Dr Strange
Avengers more Captain America she's like
a superwoman but you've not seen these
things
okay I knew I was okay
that's so funny like how my confusion
just came full circle I
have no idea who Elizabeth Olsen is I'm
just learning something new about myself
like I've never seen her in anything I
just know
I'm at Elle Fanning she was incredible
in the girl from Plainview that that
[ __ ] show was twisted yeah she's
another one because little sis made it
big yeah see that's why I got them
confused little sis made it big I
confused her with the snitch too
who wouldn't
energy
um happy for those sins hoping for a
pick mazel tov are you ready for our
next story oh and I guess he's Jewish
Eisner
so is she us
es
a Christian
she could be a Jew and believe in God
wouldn't this be our fifth and final
this next one will be our fifth and
final yeah you said are you ready for
our next story it is both next and Fifth
and Final
good okay yes I'm ready Jen Shaw's
federal case
um has just thrown a wrench a wrench has
been thrown by a 2019 restraining order
is coming back to haunt her ahead of the
sentencing Jen Shaw's upcoming sentence
which she will be sentenced today might
be I know so I was just gonna say I was
checking to see if there's an update I I
don't think it'll be for a while but by
the time you listen to this episode like
it might be out whenever you listen to
this episode we'll have the recap
tomorrow but it's today like after all
of this like it's finally happening I
don't know why I'm smiling it's like not
funny
um but her sentencing might be stiffer
thanks to a woman who informed the feds
about a restraining order she once got
against the reality star and prosecutors
want the judge to take it into account
prosecutors and sheds federal fraud case
just filed new docs this weekend Accord
to consider a 2019 restraining order
obtained by a woman who claims she had
once had some trouble with the star the
feds say the woman reach out to them via
letter and now want the judge to take a
look at how she described their
interaction with Jen's upcoming
sentencing hearing on Friday oh sorry
tomorrow not today prosecutors want to
make sure the judge sees what the woman
had to say because they believe it to be
consistent with how Jen has interacted
with others in other words they think
the woman's account will back what they
claim they've discovered about Jen's
character throughout these proceedings
and it seems like prosecutors are hoping
it leads to a harsher sentence now I
think this is coming because Jen also
her team put forth a statement like you
know asking for leniency Jen is this and
that is a mother a wonderful person and
so this woman saying like no she's not I
have a restraining order against her
like she's none of those things she's
nothing of this sort
I mean I feel like it's so crazy for the
federal government to like literally add
more evidence to your case the day
before sentencing like they're
definitely like trying to make an
example out of Jen and you know what
like Jen's crimes like
I always I'm always going to compare
Jen's crimes to like Chrisley or Teresa
Jen's crimes are so egregious like the
that's what I'm saying yesterday it's
like I know the Chrisleys did something
wrong but like I'm not going to feel bad
like stealing from a bank like the bank
is going to be fine you can share Jen's
crimes to the Chrisleys I can I compare
this whole Saga like the the trial and
the eventual sentencing of like reality
stars like I'm always going to compare
them okay okay but the difference here
is like even like I know that Chrisley's
did did something wrong I know but I
still do feel bad for them like they're
you know they they did that [ __ ] but
like literally you're not gonna find me
crying over the banks even though they
did give us that federal holiday
um but with Jen it's like what she did
is so
evil
no I start to feel bad for her
especially when I would watch her
episodes
I do start to feel bad for her and then
I think about what she did and I'm cured
right like it's so egregious and it's so
evil and so I'm so funny I'm seeing so
much discourse I have stopped watching
The Real Housewives of Salt Lake City
and I'm seeing so much discourse online
right now like two things happening like
one people like quaking over Jen's
eventual sentencing and the trial and
tomorrow and then also people talking
about this current season of Salt Lake
City who gave Heather the black eye
oh Jazz tickets
so [ __ ] stupid and I feel like I'm
now even more Resolute in my decision to
not watch the season the fact that like
these two things are going on at the
same time and like the show isn't like
really digging deep and talking about
and showing the trial stuff and we're
wasting so much time on Lisa sucking
someone's dick for Utah Jazz tickets
like it's so stupid and I just I can't
stress enough how like the women of Salt
Lake City have not only disappointed me
but like so drop the ball on what could
have been a historic two years two
seasons last year was the arrest and
then this year was the trial what could
have been like two of the most historic
like could have been studied in
production textbooks how they dropped
the ball yeah I mean in the same way
they like went and found old members of
Mary's Church to talk about you know
their donations like why don't you go
find some of Jen's victims and talk
about what happened or This Woman This
Woman 2019 uh restraining order yeah no
but like let's hear about the experience
of someone who fell for Jen's
telemarketing scheme how their life was
ruined
yeah I just I cannot believe that like
these two things are going on at the
same time it's such a disappointment
yeah I'm very curious what the sentence
will be tomorrow like it's gonna be big
I know and then I'm just I'm like
looking forward to comparing it to the
Chrisley one though I can't I don't
think the crimes are comparable I in
terms of I I compare the Chrisleys to
Teresa I compare Jen to Tom Girardi yes
that's a good call I forgot about
Jessica and Tom ripping off innocent
people and taking advantage of
vulnerable and vulnerable
yeah no it'll be very interesting I mean
it's kind of like the craziest thing
that's ever happened in Housewives
history yeah and they're not even
talking about it on the show yeah also
what I wanted to say is this woman put
forth this like character statement
about Jen so that they would know of her
character
um the judges just watched season one
real house of Salt Lake City like it's
pretty clear like
yeah like it's she doesn't come off like
the sweetest kindness lady
no and I do often think about like how
the show plays a role in the trial like
when you're doing jury selection like
are you allowed to select people who
have seen the show because that gives
them a preconceived notion even though
with this federal case sorry I don't
think there's a jury
did it go to trial no because she pled
yeah sorry there's no jury but just like
in things like this like I think how
does the what if the judge has seen the
show I think well if the judge was like
seriously involved in some way like he
would have accused himself I think with
jury selection though someone can have
watched the show and like know who Jen
is but they have to be you know adamant
in that they're by like they have no
partial advice would not influence them
and you know it couldn't be like you
were I who watched the show and have a
podcast like you know what I mean but
it's someone who's a passive Watcher
they could maybe get onto the jury but
also if she her behavior on the show was
really terrible then the defense won't
want her but like on Teresa's trial
maybe the defense would want someone who
watched the show because I think a lot
because people who watch the show had a
lot of sympathy for her no and a lot of
people watch a show have like a real
understanding how like Teresa does not
live in this world like she does not
know what goes on around her she's not
the brightest like there's no way she
could be the Mastermind of some big tax
evasion scheme yeah
yeah that's a good point but with these
with these Federal trials like they
often don't have cherries I don't know
if it's because they pled guilty or
because I don't think Federal trials
have juries but Amber and Johnny had a
cherry right that wasn't a federal trial
it wasn't like this like the this the US
government the like is is coming for Gen
cha with Johnny and it was Amber and
John but are you always
entitled to a jury
like yes but like Federal cases like the
FBI like it's different
I'm almost 100 no there's something
different about Federal there is
something different
like the lawyers listening to this
wanting to like kill us no the lawyers
that lawyers are always really patient
with us and then they just they don't
sit they don't like come in nasty in the
comments they just explain in the
comments there are two types of cherries
serving different functions in the
federal trial courts a trial jury also
known as a petite jury and a grand jury
okay so there is a jury yeah Jerry's the
kind of word you say so many times it
starts this out sure
yeah you are always entitled to a jury
of your peers that's you know part of
our Bill of Rights
okay but so sometimes in a criminal case
it can be decided through a trial by
judge instead of a jury and that's known
as a bench trial so it doesn't that's
like Judge Judy
right there's no jury
because then it would be too much of an
alliteration to have Judge Judy's jury
I like
you ever like have an idea that you know
would solve The World's problems yeah
I feel like
the way that like being a juror isn't
like a full-time job like the way we
have to everyone do their civil service
and people are so moronic and like
unreliable I feel like the fact that
like every courthouse in the country
doesn't have like 50 jurors on staff
first of all I'm creating jobs you're
welcome second of all you go through
extensive like bias training like kind
of how like you know like almost like
you work for the CIA like you have to go
through like really really rigorous
training to make sure you're totally
impartial and I just feel like there'd
be less error there would be less
you know people having to do jury duty
and I don't know I just feel like it's a
kind of a good call like professional
jurors for a living I hear you I respect
you I completely disagree with you
okay I think that would open up a whole
industry literally of jury tampering
all you had to do is get through the
questioning and all of a sudden your
professional juror who wants the freedom
no but it'd have to be really rigorous
like the CIA like training like a seal
but
there's so many
cases every single day like and also
you're gonna go through that training to
be a jury member why not go be a Navy
SEAL
okay well it's not like physical
training it's emotional and mental I
don't know I the more I think about it
like we're always talking about how our
judicial system is so flawed and I feel
like it's because people also people
everyday people are morons every case is
so different that no matter who you are
there will be a case that you are biased
against because you have a an experience
with it in your personal life okay but
your training would lead you to having
to recuse yourself
the training is so good it's all in the
training my idea my it's all in the
training it's a good [ __ ] idea I
disagree
I don't think our our current system
like is perfect but I think it works and
I think that people do need to play a
part in their civic duty
and I know jury duties you know stinks
and we all make jokes about it but
it's a privilege and a right
um I don't agree but it's okay for you
to be wrong this one time don't worry I
got you okay go put together your fur
profit jury duty no let me just say how
like I it's just my idea I'm giving it
to the government I don't I don't know
the proper training I've never been on a
jury it's just an idea and it's the
right idea and you guys can take it and
then make it good okay and I will be
part of the contingency
that's go voting against this and then
maybe if you're on trial for a crime you
can choose a jury of your peers or a
jury of jurors
so that you could pay them off
no
it's a good idea the more I think about
it let me know thoughts in the comments
thoughts in the comments
sorry so much for a fabulous episode Jax
always a pleasure tomorrow's our final
episode of the week and then I'll head
out to LA and we'll be back
on West Coast time starting on Monday so
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the fastest stories you
need to know everybody through Friday on
YouTube so you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available podcast
talented we are hope you guys have a
crab Thursday and we'll see you tomorrow
for Friday Friday gotta get down on
Friday
bye y'all love ya bye